what's going on reject nation Greg
outlet here with Kelly Rousseau guys she
actually did an interview with me that I
haven't promoted at all in any of these
videos the podcast what's that podcast
called pod crash with Harry Howard no
Kelly
text you right now but he's awesome he's
my co-host he's fun Harry Harry Harry
[Music]
what's going on guy say we're gonna
watch a trailer for a movie that can't
it has a trailer out weeks ago for
Netflix called maniac Jonah Hill and
yema stone before we go into this I
wanna get a patron today shout out to a
man named Niraj Krishnan Niraj lives all
the way in the east coast he's an
awesome patron I want to show you out
here because if anyone's a psychopathic
maniac is this guy telling you no one at
patreon gives me more cautionary vibes
like Niraj shout out I just feel like
Niraj needs some psychological help
should also increase his pledge a
patriot I'm hoping this is the way to
persuade you to no Niraj is actually
like an unbelievably supportive guy and
he's always there for us no matter what
and he's always giving great suggestions
of what to check out I don't mean the
latter part of that shout out only hit
for you know is I'm just messin with him
or ahem I let's watch this hey they were
in Superbad together yeah but taking him
back all the way back to high school so
I bet this trailer is gonna be just as
funny yes that let's find out oh wow
my house it's like black mirror yeah do
you know where you are right now give me
a job drew what do you think is wrong
with you I'm sick he looks I don't
matter
Oh this trial is showing you about
yourself it's therapy no it's not
therapy it's science
well there's kind of the same okay yeah
can't be once you begin to appreciate
the structure of the mind there's no
reason to believe that anything about us
can't be changed
oh hey can be destroyed the mind can be
solved is that Chuck it's Justin Theroux
yeah I thought maybe these people can
fix me sounds stupid doesn't sound
stupid to me
people let's begin
blast-off what
okay who cannot what bats in this
trailer
[Music]
these wrong what did you do my
separating you just find their way back
together
there's so many cherish
[Applause]
I don't I don't know what to say it
looks awesome how have I missed this
trailer what in the world
holy crap that looks awesome my mind's
like blown right now that looks so
awesome cary fukunaga did she protected
her cary fukunaga reverse isn't a true
detective it's a limited series which is
something he seems like he excels in
this kind of looks like a scarier
Trippier version of Eternal Sunshine of
the spotless mind totally in some ways I
like a lot of movies and shows but I
like movies that deal with exploring the
mind I think of like the Sal Eternal
Sunshine because there's endless
possibilities and weirdness you can do
right because at first I was like okay
this seems like some weird eighties kind
of sci-fi movie cuz I like that
technology designs they have in the
first half of this trailer like the
technology and the science rooms look
kind of about David and his hairstyle
and everything looks like are they from
a different era because kind of the
practical mics and cameras totally the
TV yeah they form an earlier era yeah
but then when they're doing all the
crazy different mind exploration stuff
that's like are they tampering with them
there's this movie that I saw
I'm travel type you time travel if you
see the earlier video you get why she
said it anyway the time travel I mean
that's so hard to do and you have to
have a big budget do it any period piece
it's gonna be the first true detective
or a time travel you said the time
travel is us as you know the audience we
times the time lapses in every time
lapse
we don't have Jones travel no it's this
is the first sci-fi version of true
detective every time again there was
this movie I saw forever ago
I think it's star Jeff Bridges it's
called altered states how it works is
with one of those that go into the mind
things supposedly with this theory of
that movie is if you go into the mind
you can also trace back DNA and mind
thoughts all the way to your answer
stirs and stuff oh so it's like a weird
trippy ass film they're kind of going
into different eras here so I don't know
if they're doing something like that
like going it's a past lives of
themselves or their ancestors or they're
just kind of inserting weird memories
into their brain right
but either way Total Recall yeah I did a
good job on the reference there good job
on the reference back and what I love
too about what they're doing with the
different explorations is seems to be
genre splicing a lot completely you got
ones where they're in you know long hair
and they're medieval times then you got
ones or the 50s you got ones where
they're holding guns and it looks like
an action movie and then you got ones
they're just trippy ass
sci-fi noir types of deals going on here
is the first half I'm like why they get
Emma Stone and Jonah Hill it looks like
they're kind of is giving MD
performances and when you're doing those
different explorations I'm like oh this
makes more sense cuz you got but you
what a weird ass films are you reunite
these guys were so weird by it
miniseries yeah that series yeah those
John back there John is there to
fact-check us there's a limited series
earlier in the video yeah but like it's
every actors dream like literally you
could do this one show and be done like
there every genre yeah Hollywood glamour
Legolas like not just time-travel it's
like big fantasy fan is I'm kind of
wondering though I'm all for the
exploration I'm all for the weirdness
yeah but what's the actual like linear
plot that's going on here what's gonna
you know like with yeah Total Recall
like you brought up he has saved the
world you know and they just find out
this is real or dissolved in his mind or
eternal sunshine he's trying to erase
his ex-girlfriend from his mind what
exactly is going on here other than
experimentation are they trying to break
free from this do they have to figure
out the game so they can stop being
these human test subjects like what is
the actual plot other than cool visuals
and cool expiration because sometimes
that artistic miss can get a little
meandering and a little self-indulgent I
want to know where is this journey
actually going and I feel like they'll
be plot to us because I mean here and
he says I want to heal the way of my
brain functions right I'm sure it'll be
like little you can't get out of that
but we'll see
and I imagine - you know there's that
line in there earlier about it's not
therapy it's science
I imagine they're probably gonna do some
type of self mental health healing by
the end of this there's got to be some
type of character artwork
right they overcome something in their
mind that's been holding them back or
restraining them in some capacity and or
else or might not be a worthwhile
journey I feel if you're gonna go into
the mind this depth you got to be
letting something go I don't feel like
that lines gonna be entirely true that
I'm a there's some type of therapeutic
feeling they're gonna generate from this
in the end yeah or they're just gonna go
insane cuz it's called maniac so I'm
wondering why is it called maniac
exactly spoiler alert they just go crazy
Lord they just go crazy kill everyone
and they go insane by the end of the
movie and cary fukunaga he hasn't had
the best of luck
with doing films lately like he was
originally gonna do it that went through
development hell with him God different
director for him to return to a limited
series I think is a great thing for
someone like me who watched his true
detective work i watch that all in a
binge fest and for netflix you know it's
gonna be a binge fast the best fast the
best fast hey you're a poet and you did
it again you're rhyming again call back
to another video
no anyway guys thanks for so many weeks
asking me to do this and I'm sorry for
doing this so late but I'm glad Kelly
was here you seem like you really
enjoyed it I loved it you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell because of youtube
crap
check out Kelly on the Instagram and
Twitter where she's constantly tweeting
poetry and rhyme schemes and on
Instagram where she's always you know
dressed in full-bodied suits
never anything very sensual no ankle no
Michael that's the new laws out here
she's very age-appropriate so little
girls will grow up wanting to be just
like her Oh God
don't say all this no gonna get proper
from
Oh she'll have four bikini photos up
next week people look down ladies and
gentlemen I'm going to delete my speech
just gonna get a bunch of comments
though where's your damn bikini photos a
Greg promise
thank you Greg thanks for ruining my
online career you're welcome Kelly I'm
glad to give you that very temporary
boost on your social media